dans quelques semaines pour ne pas dire
dans quelques jours va débuter la Coupe
d'Afrique des Nations de football la 34e
édition de la canne et tous les regards
seront braqués sur la Côte
d'Ivoire
pendant à peu près une quinzaine
d'années nous n'avions plus de stade en
Côte d'Ivoire nous étions obligés
d'aller jouer à l'extérieur pour les
matchs de la Côte d'Ivoire le président
a compris qu'il était important d'offrir
à sa jeunesse un environnement et des
condition d'épanouissement donc ces
infrastructures qui sont faites donc
permettent déjà de créer un système et
une économie qui va se bâtir autour de
[Musique]
ça une fois qu'on aura offert cette
canne toutes les dispositions seront
prises pour que la sécurité soit assurée
pour que les conditions je dirais de de
de vie de qualité soi assuré dans la
ville d'Abidjan pour ceux qui
connaissent la Côte d'Ivoire il y a un
il a il y a un adage qui dit Abidjan est
c'est c'est universel et donc nous
allons faire en sorte que tous les
étrangers
apprécient